Oh Kryptonian
[Music]
was really for
like all the others
how many of you are there not enough do
you really think that oh wow they just
they really just vanish huh oh that's
rude
[Music]
hey everybody reverse-flash couldn't
have said it better there's so many
Justice League things that you guys have
been asking me to make a video for so I
figured this would be a good opportunity
because there's a lot of good things
that have been happening but because so
much stuff has been happening behind the
scenes there's a lot of confusion and
because they haven't really started
their Justice League marketing campaign
yet so we'll say there's a new round of
the flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video I'll announce a
new winner at the end of this and the
funny thing about that is that Ezra
Miller was actually talking about the
costume flash ring in the flash movie
universe so I'll address that in a
second but the big stuff you guys want
to know about is what's up with Justice
League because the studio just did an
assembly cut screening of it last week
everyone was sworn to secrecy but of
course a bunch of people broke their
embargo and started posting about it on
social so we learned a couple of the big
changes that they made to it the biggest
one being that it sounds like Lex Luthor
has been completely cut out of the film
which I'm totally fine with because it's
all about bringing the Justice League
together facing Steppenwolf setting up
this big Darkseid threat that'll be
coming down the pipe later so there's
just so many things that are going on in
the movie that if they want to save the
Lex Luthor character for the next Man of
Steel movie that's totally okay and
honestly I don't think that it had
anything to do with the polarizing
reaction to Jesse Eisenberg's version of
Lex Luthor I think the fact that there
were just so many story elements and
characters going on they probably just
decided to opt for simplicity not to
draw attention away from the main
narrative the other really big inside
baseball Joss Whedon news that just
dropped was that he's gonna get a
screenwriting credit from the writers
guild on Justice League in that might
not sound like a big deal but in order
to be credited as a writer on a big
Hollywood movie like that
you have to write 30% of the movie it's
ironclad so a lot of people were like
wait a minute he changed 30% of the
movie that's a giant chunk of the movie
because we knew that he was working on
the script way back for reshoots
but we really didn't know how big of a
role he would play in the film because
it's still Zack Snyder's film that's
what they keep saying but the fact that
he gets the writing credit means that he
did a lot of work on it so the really
inside baseball explainer for that is
that what probably happened is is that
yeah he changed a bunch of stuff but the
reason why he's getting that
screenwriting credit is this because
they can't give him a co-director credit
with Zack Snyder because and this'll
sound really stupid the Directors Guild
of America doesn't allow for co-director
credits so like the Coen Brothers when
they make movies together only one of
the brothers gets a director credit even
if they're both directing the film so a
lot of the rumor mill on the inside is
just saying that even though Joss Whedon
changed a chunk of the movie the reason
he's getting that writing credit is just
because of some technical stuff behind
the scenes and he didn't actually
rewrite 30% of the film but at the end
of the day everybody that saw that
assembly cut this past weekend was going
crazy about it they said it was awesome
so I think it's all good news but moving
into the flash flashpoint movie so there
will be crossover with the Justice
League universe because it's sort of a
continuation of the DC EU characters as
they exist now but the really cool thing
that people found like gal gadot had to
resign her contract and there's all this
stuff going on behind the scenes because
the Wonder Woman movie did so well is
that Barry did all the language is an
option for her to cross over into the
flash movie so we're gonna get Wonder
Woman in the flash point movie which
depending on what you think they're
gonna do from the comics could either be
really awesome or just kind of awesome
because I think her character is great I
think she did an awesome job in that
movie it as long as the person that
writes and directs the flash movie does
a good job I think everything will be
just fine we don't know quite who that's
going to be but it seems like it's gonna
be Robert Zemeckis so the dream of the
Back to the Future flashpoint movie is
still alive but if you're familiar with
the flashpoint storyline it's pretty
dark and kind of depressing and they
pivoted more towards optimism in hope so
whatever version of flashpoint they do
from the comics I think it'll have a
more hopeful spin like there are a
couple big WTFs during that story
reverse flash is amazing I totally think
he's going to be a part of that story
but we don't really know what DCE
you reverse-flash is gonna look like I
assumed that because a lot of his
costume is based on Barry Allen's
costume
it'll also be more tech based but the DC
EU seems like it's doing just fine I
think the Justice League movies gonna do
great I think for the most part most of
the main actors that you see in the
Justice League movie right now will
stick around for the long haul in Ben
Affleck will continue to do Batman stuff
but here's like the big asterisk so a
lot of people heard the news about the
Joker movies that they're developing
there's a couple different Joker movies
if you have absolutely no idea what's
going on and you're scratching your head
you are not alone even I was confused
I'm like what are they trying to do I
don't understand but the funny answer to
that is that they're doing an Elseworlds
situation where you have stories that
are not set in the DC EU then Warner
Brothers goes after big oscar-winning
directors actors they don't necessarily
want to sign six picture deals so they
can get a joker movie with say Leonardo
DiCaprio and he doesn't have to sign his
life away for ten years in the way that
Ben Affleck did when he signed on to do
Batman because it's just a fundamental
truth to some of these bigger more
popular actors just don't want to sign
their life away for ten years at a time
so it's like I want to do one movie and
then that's it so that's probably why DC
is trying to do these spin-off films
that aren't connected to the DC EU like
if Martin Scorsese says he wants to
direct a DC film and Leonardo DiCaprio
says oh he's doing it I'll totally do it
they're gonna bend over backwards as far
as they can to make that happen and just
the easiest way to do that is to tell
them you don't have to worry about what
happened to Justice League this isn't
connected to any of that just make a
really awesome film that people will
enjoy so I know it's still kind of
mind-blowing but it's just the way that
Warner Brothers handles their films
they're more of a director's shop where
they bring in really great talent and
say hey you know hear these characters
please be true to them but do what you
want to do instead of having someone
like Kevin Feige say okay I'm going to
control all the creative here's the box
that you get to play in do not go
outside this box but I think what will
be interesting is is a couple years down
the road once we get all these films we
can kind of judge which method is better
I think it'll lead to some really
interesting DC films but I do think that
Marvel is also doing a really awesome
thing too so it's just two completely
different ways of in
your big cinematic universe but really
like the last big thing I know people
have been asking about Matthew Vaughn
may be doing a Man of Steel movie that
was actually in talks a while ago I've
already made a video about it so I'll
link it at the end of this it was talked
about earlier this year and he made
comments about it years ago like way
long time ago he was in talks to do it
it went away now he might wind up doing
it again but I guess we'll see I'll do
videos when they announced big stuff but
you start expecting a whole bunch more
Justice League stuff to start dropping
in the next couple months but you'll
probably hear more news about test
screenings and people reacting to
different cuts of the film in the next
couple weeks but what'll happen is is
there'll be a bunch more flash arrow DC
TV stuff dropping in the next couple
weeks because that's all coming back
flash is gonna be crazy this year I'll
be doing flash ring giveaway all season
long so if you're not subscribed make
sure you click that bell so you don't
miss any of the videos and leave all
your bonus video requests too for DC EU
stuff as well congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner shishi KO willis
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there'll be a new round
when I post a new DC video you can click
here for brand new flash footage and you
can click here to listen to Matthew
Vaughn talk about his idea for a Man of
Steel movie thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight